comme un bon jour il y at il déjà du
monde sur place racontez-nous ce qui se
passe actuellement autour de vous
voter plusieurs milliers de personnes
rassemblées sur cette place de la
république vous allez le voir
initialement cette manifestation devait
se diriger en direction de la place de
la nation
et puis finalement les organisateurs ont
annoncé il ya quelques instants que la
préfecture de police de paris avait
finalement interdit le déplacement de la
manifestation en leur demandant donc de
rester sur cette place de la république
conséquence à un certain nombre de
manifestants a décidé et bien d'engager
tout de même le parcours en direction de
la place de la nation et vous voyez ils
ont été arrêtés par les gendarmes qui
sont déployés ainsi que des membres de
la brave qui se sont rapidement déployés
pour contenir cette manifestation qui
doit donc selon les autorités rester ici
place de la république rassemblement
donc pour marquer le deuxième
anniversaire du mouvement de
contestation populaire mais le 22
février 2019 en algérie notamment pour
protester contre le fait que à l'époque
le président bouteflika ait voulu
briguer un nouveau mandat finalement à
bouteflika avait donc quitté le pouvoir
en algérie mais ici les manifestants
continuent de réclamer un changement de
système ils ne sont pas satisfaits par
les changements qui ont eu lieu depuis
maintenant deux ans dans le pays je
propose d'écouter quelques
revendications que nous avons recueillis
cet après midi c'est avec dj milo je
tiens
la publicité le peuple algérien pour sa
résistance contre ce pouvoir totalitaire
qui veut nous empêcher l'aide de bâtir
notre état de droit
tout d'abord et secundo cette plaque là
elle signifie qu'il y a des gens qui se
torture dans les prisons en algérie pour
leur simple opinion
c'est un moment historique parce que
l'algérie vit dans son histoire comme ça
des épisodes historiques
là c'en est un le premier acte bien
évidemment a été arraché l'indépendance
d'un état
il s'agit aujourd'hui d'arracher la
souveraineté pleine et entière du peuple
algérien donc la révolution du peuple
algérien pour la démocratie pour sa
souveraineté a commencé depuis très
longtemps mais il ya eu une étape qui
était le 22 février 2019
et là c'est une autre étape il faut
noter que cette semaine le président
algérien de boon a souhaité donner
quelques signes d'apaisement notamment
en libérant des prisonniers un site en
appelant à des élections anticipées dans
le pays mais ce n'est pas suffisant pour
les milliers de personnes qui sont
rassemblés ici il faut noter évidemment
qu'il y aura également des
rassemblements en algérie dans les
prochains jours plusieurs appels à
manifester ont été lancés notamment sur
les réseaux sociaux et puis une mes
revendications qui revient ici aussi
c'est le fait de reprochés la complicité
c'est comme ça qu'ils appellent la
complicité de certains pays occidentaux
de certains pouvoirs en place dont la
france avec donc le pouvoir en algérie
un pouvoir qu'il vous l'aurez compris ne
convient pas du tout aux personnes qui
sont rassemblés ici
cet homme abonné merci beaucoup thomas
boney m
envoyée spéciale en direct de la place
de la république